okay and as much as i'm worried about
these loons who break into government
i'm actually more worried about the
loons who did get elected
because i i mean what do you do about
these people there's 147
republicans in congress who still don't
concede
that trump lost the election what do you
do about people who are in the
government
who don't believe in our way of
it is so shocking not only do are they
not conceding bill but
there's thoughts that there might have
been some collusion
among members of congress some are
refusing to go through magnum
magnometers or whatever you call them to
to check for weapons
they're not wearing masks during the
siege i mean it's
really bizarre isn't it when you think
about how awol so many of these members
of congress have gotten
but i also think some of them are
believing the garbage that they are
being fed
24 7 on the internet by their
constituents and they bought into this
big
lie and the question is how are we going
to
really almost deprogram these people who
have signed up
for the cult of trump
[Music]
what's going on people we are live we
are broadcasting on
facebook rt thank you all of our
beautiful international audience members
that are out there
in different countries we thank you for
watching
thank you for sharing we thank you for
participating
uh we're also broadcasting on the last
days of periscope
so if you are out there and you're on
your last days of periscope
uh make sure that you
well we've already told you that uh we
are moving
operations to d live and to rumble when
rumble
goes with their um with their uh
live streams yeah to my left your right
is leah bellerin guys what's up leah
hey make sure you're sharing the show
don't forget to do that
leah what's on your mind real quick i
don't like that katie kirk thing i'm
real bothered
i can tell you that right now i just
want to say this i know you got to
introduce brian but
when she says that it's like she needs
reprogram because katie couric
actually didn't report her co-workers
being sexually harassed by matt lauer
because she was under the spell of nbc
in the today show
so really she should be the one to
deprogram her dead husband would be
rolling over in his grave
because she he was not like that at all
he would not appreciate what she's doing
there
sickening she's trying to be relevant
again she can go to hell
brian they're talking about deep deep
not only deep platforming
but deprogramming you at the same time
well if they gonna do another
colonoscopy on her
on live tv i don't want nothing to do
with that one either
i don't care if that was in tribute over
her husband or not
but that's just something the public
doesn't need to see ever
okay sorry we are not programmed to be
trumpers we are programmed as america
first make america great again whether
it's trump or whether it's not trump
we want america to be first in the world
you know what i'm so i'm so glad well
it's funny that you said that because
i was thinking this morning i was
thinking this morning
about what is going to happen to
the mag of movement now notice i didn't
say trump movement
i said what is going to happen to the
mega movement because
the movement donald trump
saw that this country was was being led
down the wrong
direction by these by these career
politicians
so he got behind two individuals they
couldn't jump start
a tricycle
and when they didn't get in he was like
well let me go ahead and do it myself
but the movement is not him
he's he ignited the movement so
i guess my question to both y'all is
where does the movement go
from here
if there's not another leader that's
going to step up and start singing the
praises of america
and america first and be damned with all
this political correctness which is
what we the majority of the people
actually believe and think when we go
about our daily lives we
joke around at work or we jump around
hanging out with our friends about how
political correctness has destroyed
america
and we're done with that and when donald
trump says i'm not politically correct
and i don't care
this is what it is illegal immigration
is wrecking our country
and it's got to stop we all know that to
be true
so we just need leaders that have the
america first agenda
and start to vocally speak it and then
physically your actions have to
uh have to follow that as well so but i
think the movement can continue on
well i think that in order to
love what you have you have to lose it
and what i mean by that is i'm talking
about the left
um go ahead they want to push joe
biden's um
ideas and uh push all of his new roles
that he wants to bring in go ahead
see how that works out do you ever see a
country that goes to socialism
have you ever seen what happens to
countries that do that you got teenagers
out on the streets hunting
cats for food when it gets that bad okay
so sometimes you have to hit rock bottom
until you realize and you take a step
back wow
until it affects uh the alyssa milanos
of the world the lady gagas of the world
they're not gonna see it
once they start seeing that they're
becoming banned off twitter because
twitter will eat their own
once they start to see that they're
being censored their money's being
messed with because it will happen when
it comes to socialism it will happen
then they'll take a step back and go
okay maybe these trump supporters
weren't as bad as what i thought
you know i don't like it that you know
my kids are being forced to
get vaccines you know because it will
happen at some point
so i think that they have to see and
suffer
before they can understand where we're
coming from and
that will help but it's going to take a
while that's where i see that's what i
see happening
because i don't see a change right now i
wish i could tell you i do
but this is the reality that we're
living in joe's coming into office
tomorrow
yeah at 12 noon i think and
i hope i hope y'all don't think that i'm
throwing salt on the moon
here because i'm not i
it's just that i've had many questions
about a lot of these predictors and a
whole lot of these
well predictions and a whole lot of
these um
gaslighters for the last two and a half
years three years and it's kind of fr
it's frustrated me it's pissed me off
it's made me angry
that many americans
supported that type of talk about things
that could
happen and stuff and they put their hope
in the social media
uh accounts and now now tomorrow at 12
noon joe biden is going
to accept the oath to be the president
of the united states
and where are these people going to be
creating more predictions about
things that might i that that could
happen that won't happen
we need we need individuals that are
going to be out there and telling the
god during truth and that i mean i mean
honestly i'm sick and tired of watching
these these people get catapulted
up on these pedestals like
like there's some type of uh uh uh uh
i don't know i don't even know the word
for it oh all i know is i'm getting sick
and tired of watching this happen
and americans are being hurt
every day by this fantasy talk
when they should be turning things
around and saying you know what
we gotta get out there a whole lot more
we gotta like
like we've been saying on the show we
gotta get
involved with community politics we
gotta we have to
we have to um uh start getting elected
to these local boards so we can change
things we're so so we can create our
roots on the ground
because there's nothing better than
creating roots
because when you create roots and they
go deep enough you can't move them out
you can't move them out right when you i
think what
you might be referring to as like modern
day uh
prophets if you will people that
self-proclaim prophets
um and it just reminds me something that
happened last week but i watched as uh
someone prayed over a woman that was
really heavy set
and dying of diabetes and falling apart
and praying that god bless her and take
all those diseases away
and as i was done and i was watching i i
looked and i'm like man
i want to be the guy that goes out to
her and say hey
by the way that's all true but you also
need a lifestyle change
so so you can pray for america and pray
for the greatness and good things to
come
but but how we get there and god will
bless us
but how we get there we've got to
actually physically do
something like you say hey god please
bless america
and then go home and sit home and don't
do nothing and
and gain three or four hundred pounds
now you gotta actually
get out there and do it and god will
open the doors for you
so those things happen is that making
sense
yeah and people in the chat are asking
well who is it who are you talking about
call them out you know who they are
you know what yeah exactly who they are
because they haven't been right
so go through your twitter account and
if they've been telling you a storm is
coming
okay the storm didn't come right right i
mean
it's like it's like um
this is old saying a dog a
if dog will bring a bone a dog will
carry a bone
okay basically what you want us to do
and say
joe schmoello did this so you can go on
joe schmoe timeline
and say you know wayne's talking and and
create a whole lot happen
you know who has bullshitted
a lot of you on a whole lot of things
and y'all haven't called him the task on
it
you haven't and i know that unless i
just curse and this is not what the show
is about
but that's what y'all have that's what a
whole lot of y'all have done
you have pushed the truth off to the
side and you have let these people
every day every minute
on the period of each of these people's
sentences
and don't you know that hurt president
trump
don't you under don't y'all realize that
these people were in it for themselves
enriching themselves off of his name
and now he's going out i mean honestly i
really feel bad
and i promise you i'm not going to get
emotional i'm not i'm not going to get
emotional
on this one because i remember when he
came down the steps
i remember when he came down steps he
left his business to come down the steps
to run for president
and now he
has
the establishment has taken away his
ability
i've never seen anything like this his
life is gone his life is literally
not what it will ever
and you could you could continue because
uh
we've got mcconnell this possibly you
guys could continue
to go ahead and wreck this guy and go
after him and go after him
and beat the dead horse when it's down
kick it kick it even more because
that's how vicious you people are you're
coming after trump supporters
you're still coming at us with the
rhetoric of nazis
uh white supremacists uh race's biggest
sex is homophobe and it's not
stopping from you people like katie
couric said
dude we gotta we gotta reprogram and joe
biden if he's serious
about making peace and unity he needs to
come out and say to her
you know what katie shut up sit your ass
down and don't be saying things like
that because you're causing drama where
there doesn't need to be drama
a lot of this hollywood needs to check
themselves before they get themselves in
trouble
and that's honest to god's truth katie
couric lost so much respect off of
people that actually enjoyed what she
had done in her life
she's losing that now and she's no
better than what she was calling out to
begin with
shame honor yeah if if joe biden was
serious
about one unity he wouldn't be starting
out like he is with these america last
policies
because because that's exactly where
he's going
america last policies and
uh if i have a message to president
trump
uh and i've known him for a little bit
i wish you the best i do i wish you the
best i wish that
i hope that you go down to mar-a-lago i
hope that you take some time to yourself
and i hope that you recoup
yourself and i hope that you gather
yourself back together
because i understand what they have done
to you i understand what the media has
done to you
you talk about 94 95 negative news for
about three and a half years
negative news cycle yep they stripped
away his facebook they stripped away his
twitter when nobody's i when everybody
said that it can't be done they did it
you know they they um they think that
they're taking away his voice
you you can't take away a billionaire's
voice now
uh some companies are saying that
they're not going to work with him
going forward you know whatever he i
mean
if there's one thing i know about
president trump he's a survivor
he is a survivor and there are a whole
lot of people out there
that have been surviving off of his name
big paul said well why didn't you say
anything
uh during what we did and nobody listen
yeah we've been talking about this
nobody listening paul
so i mean again
uh people want to live in a fantasy of
uh there there is no
bad out there there there's nothing bad
out there that everything is moving fine
everything is going fine how many times
did i talk about
i wasn't happy about the syria thing
everybody said trust the plan
because i believe that um
uh paul uh mccain and um lindsey graham
lied to him
about that uh uh about that uh casting
of those people over there
guessing on the people i was like what
are you serious gasoline people and then
when we saw reports
from people saying no no ain't nobody
guessed anything
those all those old pictures oh but
nobody wanted to believe us
nobody wanted to jump on our side when
we were talking about
that's that's just too much trillion
that's just too much
money in those honors bills president
trump don't do that we didn't trust the
plan trust the plan
he president trump is playing 40 chests
we
wait you're negative no
i understood what every i understood
what we said about barack obama when he
was spending up all that damn money and
now a sudden
they they just laid it on trump and the
first part of his
thing and all y'all are like
it what i mean honestly it wasn't even
funny it wasn't funny it was
it was scary because they kept
a fiscal creature check off fiscal there
are no fiscal conservatives in the
congress anymore
and i did i dare want them to come out
against any of the democrats spending
money i dare i
dare them to come out after all the
money that they shoved
um into trump's face
and and lied to him by the wall lied to
him about the military lied to him about
different things i i dare y'all i dare
you and
i just feel like campaigning against gop
period that's me
there's uh there's another camp that
that's not too far
off from that i'm i'm with you in the
sense that
we need to start going after these
you drink from the wrong one
y'all got me i mean i'm not y'all but
well good thing you don't dip and you
drank from the wrong one oh i
i did that with my dad i thought it was
soda my dad was chewing stuff
uh copenhagen fine cut spitting it into
his coca-cola can when i was a kid
i thought it was coca-cola and took a
drink and it was my dad's fit from a
snack
that's why i hope y'all out there who
did there's something really wrong with
that stuff
yeah it was really really gross i i've
not been able to drink coca-cola since
then i really haven't
yeah i mean look the rnc and the dnc are
cousins
don't get it requested the army and the
nc are cousins as a matter of fact
i'm sure right now you could find
a hundred married couples split between
both parties
they're kissing cousins
[Laughter]
well i mean i mean you saw what the
bushes did
you saw how they cuddled up and then all
of a sudden reports come out that the
the papa bush and george w bush all do
barack obama being raised up
i mean george w bush they're best
friends with michelle obama they
they're like that wasn't me it's almost
uncomfortable like she puts her arms
around him
you know she has a chocolate for him
every time she sees him she gives him a
chocolate
yeah there's a connection that he has
with her with obama
yeah from back in the day it's all right
know what he said did you say
uh wayne that going back through all the
presidents we've ever had that there's
some
something to do with the relationship
between the president the hierarchy
yeah except for with president trump as
long
as you go back to george washington
they have found even barack obama has
some connection with
some of the the president lineage you
know how
the forefathers left england because
they didn't want a monarchy and they
didn't want
you know uh royalty and different things
like that well that's basically what
america has been because there's a
lineage of where everybody is connected
well not everybody well i mean you know
whatever yeah i know what i'm talking
about
the presidents are connected except for
president trump
president trump was not connected to any
one of them and that's why he was seen
as the outsider
and that's why you know i was looking at
the thing
this morning and they were talking about
and they're posed for everything and
and if you watch the show you know that
we don't follow the polls we don't put
polls up on here
because polls can be maneuvered by
either party
but the polls are being but the reason
why i'm telling you this is because
they don't want president trump to run
again and they're trying their damnedess
to stop the americans
to some everything about him so that he
doesn't run again
the polls right now tomorrow oh
i think it's 12 noon biden has to
take oh 12 noon i think 12 noon on the
20th i think
that's was two o'clock 12.
they're trying to send trump out with
the lowest
presidential poll numbers ever it's a
narrative
it's a narrative yeah that so if he ever
runs again
they will push that narrative you will
hear that narrative over the next couple
days
as trump leaves he has the lowest
presidential polls
of all time nobody's ever had the lowest
that because they brow beat that into
the hearts and minds of americans that
don't care anything about politics ought
to hear is one thing
and then they just keep on about their
business they don't care about research
like you said before 96 of trump's
coverage for the past four years was
negative
if they continue down that road what
they're doing you know it only takes
three months to convince you
otherwise if it's a negative report
that's all it takes three months to
convince you and to make you believe
and your brain will start to believe the
negative reporting and all it does is
take three months they've been doing it
for four years
so think of how many minds they've
manipulated because they didn't share
the good stories about the nuns they
didn't share the fact that he takes
his paychecks from the white house and
donates them every single month
to someone in need including our
veterans they never told you the
positive things of trump's
uh presidency so you're left with all
these negative
opinions and feelings right right and
then this is what happens because yes
everybody can be manipulated depending
on how you skew the news
that's where we're at and it's easy to
rewrite the history books now
now that they've got all this evidence
of
news reporting and poll numbers and all
these things that they just fictitiously
made up
they can now rewrite the history books
and say oh well see
he could he couldn't even win reelection
he was destroyed because of
and look at all the poll numbers and
look he was the worst president ever
because of this
this this and this i know we made it up
back then
but i know we're referring to it now in
writing
or rewriting the history books for our
children our children's children
and i just have to say one thing i think
it's absolutely fascinating
that no one is upset and even the who
has come out now and said look china
didn't let us in they didn't let us know
the origins on covet 19.
and i just am shocked at how america is
really giving china a pass on kobe 19
because they're so obsessed with trump
and making sure that he looks bad
and we're we're all coal about this kova
19 that is
wrecking our lives we can't do anything
about it and it's china's fault let's
just be honest here
even the who is saying it and we're like
all cool about it because we all just
want to focus on what trump's doing
it doesn't make any sense to me and i
think that that is going to be a class
in itself one day
that people just sit around round tables
and talk about
because it is the most idiocy i mean it
is just insane to me
yeah the argument i had with a liberal i
brought that up about the china virus
yeah he flipped out on me lost it
yeah it just it's insane yeah um
there's a video going around i can't
play right now but i did share it on my
timeline
i watched it this morning actually i
watched all of it
um i mean it's not like i didn't see it
coming
i just didn't see it like that coming um
the video basically
is taking a whole lot of uh trump
supporter videos
including what happened on the capitol
and
i don't know if y'all remember you
remember barack obama
and his administration used to tell
people to turn
in your neighbors and turn in your yes
and stuff like
okay well that's what this video is all
about for um
individuals that have uh or or neighbors
neighbors two trump supporters or noah
trump supporter or whatnot
just talking about you need to turn them
in you need to write down their names
you need yeah you need to report them
because
they're terrorists they're associated
with
trump supporters with domestic
terrorism that's what they've been doing
oh since the last week
and that's why me brian and leah were
angry at someone
at and no any trump supporter that went
to the capitol
because you fell in for the trap what i
mean
i mean and and and you you even went
further
to prove that it was a setup
because many of you were like see look
they they open up the doors
look look they yeah yeah they open up
the doors and you all get right
and you know what the scary part is they
took i mean this is how
let me tell you the democrats are
manipulative little
sons
they took that that uh clip that you
can't play
and they actually pulled on your
emotional heartstrings by giving it a
name like they always do
and they pulled it in and said look it's
police officers it's your teachers
it's some of the military yeah the army
these people are your nurses your
doctors
that's bad when you do that that's bad
when you do that
they shouldn't be saying things like
that because then all of a sudden you
you start not trusting your neighbors
then you don't trust
your army you don't trust your military
there how is that not banned well they
want
they want this video to go viral they
the majority of america to see this
because for those of you who were
60 in trump's camp and you were like oh
i'm on trump
i'm not buying a t-shirt i'm not buying
a hat but i'm waving an american flag
and i'm voting trump
they want you to disavow trump and
trump's supporters
everybody that is not uh you know that
is
at least 60 in the trump's camp they
want to remove
all of that so that the gop has just a
very small
little trump supporting camp and they
want to remove it all and rewrite it all
yeah they don't want they don't want
unity they just want you to shut up if
you're a trump supporter and then that's
their unity
join them they don't want unity they
want
you to shut up yeah
and sign on to the notion that they're
going to give you another check shut up
shut up yeah shut up take the check
there you go
there you go there they're throwing that
they're throwing that extra
oh and y'all are gonna get it y'all are
gonna get 1400 bucks you're gonna get it
and then toward the middle of the year
no toward any year you're gonna forget
it
you're gonna it's gonna be it's gonna be
spinning
well they're suggesting that they're
gonna do it monthly now
fourteen hundred dollars a month there
was one suggestion out there by
uh who's the girl that has the disease
that made her lose her hair that's in
the squad
anna presley
and they're now looking at it that maybe
they'll get the 1400 every month
well you know if you take the 20 20 some
odd trillion we spent over
uh the middle east uh
and andrew yang he's pitching universal
income he wants fifteen thousand dollars
a month in your pocket every year
i need a million make us all
millionaires it'll be in dubai all over
again we'll be driving lamborghinis all
right
this morning this morning ladies and
gentlemen this is
national guard more troops
on the washington wall
for the inauguration of
joe biden tomorrow
early this morning more troops
shows a strong force that uh it's gonna
be peaceful and
we're not gonna be reckoned with and
twofold
it it it symbolizes or shows
whether it's true or not that the
military is behind joe
biden and that the troops support the
president
because they're all in on dc
and and i find this very disheartening
and
and it's i'm at a loss for words when
you take uh the troops and you use them
like puppets like this because there's
no reason why you're getting the
national guard reserves out of
alaska right i agree with that 100
and the thing is if it's that dangerous
there
and this is that's nervous what why why
is lady gaga performing
like no one needs to hear her
yeah no one needs to hear her saying if
this is that important
maybe not have her sing there
because right yeah i like that
i don't know if it's that if it's that
serious
why have lady gaga yeah and uh are you
putting waterfronts out there yeah
you're putting garth brooks out there
strumming the guitar and you're scared
to death because it's a dark winter
because coved
and you've got 20 000 troops lined up in
dc that's making us look like north
korea
but bring on garth brooks let him sing a
little bit
stupid i gotta protect those 200 000
flags that now represent possible 200
000 people that
may or may not have showed up at some
given point in time
you got
at least a fraction of the 80
million possible votes that joe bond got
yeah you're gonna have to
one day you're gonna have to fabricate
something right
if the pandemic is that dangerous and
the countries that were that bad with
each other
uh i can't imagine lady gaga and garth
brooks playing
as an inauguration if it's that bad this
is
let's see let me see
jesse on it yeah those flags those flags
are supposed to be
the 20th out uh there's 200
000 flags to replace the audience
it's become a spectacle it's like a
three it's literally like the ringling
brothers circus at this point
they should have just done it in private
he should have set out a respect for
everybody that suffered through covid
we're going to do it private
to have lady gaga again i go back to
that and garth brooke that is a kick
in the butt and into the chest to
everybody who has stayed home
and stayed safe but you're bringing lady
gaga out to have a concert
shouldn't she be sitting at her house
wearing a pandemic she gotta get paid
do a inaugurate do the inauguration in
private
do it in private you did everything else
in your basement do it in your damn
basement
i think that would be perfect well it
goes to never let a crisis go to waste
though
i mean i mean this this is this
is what the democrats do this is who
they
are well maybe the combo brothers will
come out on tigers and elephants
you're speaking truth to power leo what
you're saying is absolutely true
but in reality the democrats are that's
not who they are
they're the opposite of that they got to
be the showman that got to put this down
they got to make you think that
hollywood is part of all of this and
it is a kumbaya moment we are coming
together
and if you don't come together with us
take the check and shut up
otherwise you're a nazi i actually i'm
glad you said that because i feel like
politic politicians think they are the
new hollywood
and we're the paparazzi they love us
when they need us or when they want to
get their message out
but they hate us when we see them at a
restaurant without a mask on
or when they're getting their hair cut
or when we ask them about their son's
transactions in china then we're the bad
paparazzi get away from us
you know we got to hide our face and try
to run inside and get protected that's
what they are the new hollywood
i just wish politics would become boring
again
isn't it kind of well it's not funny
isn't it strange how
nothing happened over the weekend after
the fbi claimed that they were hearing
chatter about
stuff that was going to happen at the
state capitals across the country
and then nothing happened yeah that's
what that
uh the liberal i had a conversation with
last week he said you all are gonna
attack
every capital this weekend it's coming
they start reading articles about it i'm
like
because you read an article about it
does it mean it's gonna happen
yeah what are you guys doing in dayton
in columbus
well here's the report you guys gonna
burn it down uh
no we're not
does not make it true
i do um i do find it
i do find it funny uh the other thing
was strange i do find this funny
that joe one of joe biden's first order
of businesses
is okay yeah to offer
citizenship to the undocumented
immigrants but he's saying it's an
eight-year plan
you know no that means we told you
and and you know what it was insane
because i just heard
a few days ago all these illegal
immigrants that are walking up through i
don't even know where they're coming
from the caravan
joe biden's actual administration
somebody came out in the administration
said uh-uh
that's not the way you do it you're
gonna have to wait now is not
word for word now is not the time i'm
like oh man
you were promised something that you're
not getting yeah there's a big care man
coming up from honduras
yeah sorry guys yes i know i don't know
who's paying you
what
it would take eight years how long how
long does it take for
somebody that does it the right way 70
i think more than that depending on the
money you have it could take up to 10.
depending on the money
i ain't getting it you got ain't getting
it
[ __ ] yeah getting it because i mean
because if you do then what would he run
on
or what would the next democrat party
run on right and they couldn't use
illegal immigrants for votes it's got to
be a perpetual thing
when i heard that i was like eight years
then see
see that's that's what they do with
these spending budgets and stuff like
well
well the spending stuff they were like
okay um
uh we're going to do
we're going to uh give y'all a certain
amount
but on the back end is when everything
comes but usually when the backing comes
there's a new administration in there
and they cancel what the former
administration did
and then nobody ever sees anything
that's what i'm saying
y'all won't you you're never you're not
going to see
legal status it's going to be pushed
they have no
reason to give you legal status but they
have every reason
to carry you along or to download that
carrot
over you so that you keep supporting
them or
defending them when
uh when they are being attacked for
um sending people i mean or or when
republicans are being uh
attacked for sending people home or
wanting people to go back to
uh home countries and stuff well and
look at black lives matter blm
they were like joan commonly won't talk
to us yeah i
could have told you just wait till 2024
like
uh i don't know may they'll talk to you
they'll send you a postcard or something
because they need your vote again
right dialing back looking in history
ronald reagan signed the
uh amnesty bill and people that's all
they talk about they are well ricky did
it regularly
he did it with the notion that it was
also part of the package that there was
going to be a wall to be built
it was written into law and then it was
unfunded
oh sorry frankie we don't have no money
the the money that you were supposed to
get from yeah i know it's in law
so they defunded the whole damn thing
and again
as wade's point they may say something
up front but
you won't get back in to show up and
sometimes it don't never show up
no um you know i
i said i said this yesterday
and i'll say it again you know i'm just
i'm just having a hard time with these
influencers that's all
a lot of a whole lot of have become
jesus jesus supporters
these days and preaching to you but uh
they aren't they aren't spewing that oh
joe uh
joe's joe's not gonna take the oath
tomorrow
what is that what you're saying now
they're still saying that people are
still saying that
some people are still holding out hope
that hold on if joe doesn't do it
tomorrow it is because something's
happened to joe
and no laugh i mean seriously other than
that
and then camilla's to walk in and pick
it up
and i don't know what is going to happen
you know what
watch her she is not ready oh wait um
breaking news let me make sure i got
that right
breaking news mitch mcconnell
says
that president trump provoked
let me make sure i got that right
i saw it but now but now i don't see it
so i'm not going to report
that but i'm not surprised with what
he's
i could probably fill in the blank there
it's mitch mcconnell we all know
it wasn't provoked happiness we know
what he's trying to say there
you remember you remember when we were
watching uh
when when they came back and uh
mike pence sounded angry
when he was reading the thing but he
sounded angry angry
i didn't know i didn't know that they
were that close to him
and his uh and his people yeah he was
right outside the door
i didn't know that they kept him
and we were saying damn if he didn't
sound angry you know he was
he was mad and talking you know so
the thing about mitch mcconnell if mitch
mcconnell does push for
impeachment does push for more
prosecution or issues or whatnot
for donald trump i am all in the camp
with alan dershowitz who did an
interview about the whole thing
and bottom line in the past
it almost happened it was voted that you
didn't have precedent you couldn't do it
and it didn't pass by a very slim margin
so so the senate lost the power to be
able to do that
donald trump is a private citizen when
this is all said and done
and i say as alan dershowitz says i
agree with him
that the senate has no standing
in prosecuting donald trump as a private
citizen and that's how it'll go down and
all be done and said
uh i mean they'll they'll try and
perpetuate this and
keep putting it up and putting up like
something
evil that trump stay away from him he's
got the cooties
you know they're gonna do that but in
the end
trump be fine i still you know what
i'm going to take the opposite side of
what you said i think they're going to
do it
uh and i think they're going to do it
and they're going to set a precedent in
doing it just like
just like nobody ever thought that they
would impeach
the president for the second time nobody
ever did that before that's true and
i didn't think i was gonna have a second
time around right i know they wanted to
and they didn't think they had enough
time well they have to make an example
out of somebody to get their
order they have to right and they're
trying to
assassinate a political life with
president trump
and i and he and he goes back
agree with me or disagree but it goes
back to what he did on inauguration day
in 2017. he said
everybody these are the people yeah
that have hurt you the american
and they destroyed his political life
and sent him
out yeah
took away i mean now they're going to
try to take away a whole lot of his
businesses
new york de blasio say that the city of
new york is canceling
its contracts with the trump
administration
they uh uh he's uh the pentagon is
saying that they aren't going to do
uh they're going to allow the military
to do some stuff for him
tomorrow when he leaves uh
now i will say this melania trump did
come out yesterday
and again this is for all those
individuals
that said that trump ain't leaving they
say trumping
i don't think they would put melania out
there to lie
no no
very graceful my fellow americans
it has been the greatest honor of my
life to serve as first lady of the
united states
i have been inspired by incredible
americans across our country
who lift up our communities through
their kindness
and courage goodness and grace
the past four years have been
unforgettable
as donald and i conclude our time in the
white house
i think of all of the people i have
taken home in my heart
and their incredible stories of love
patriotism
and determination i see the faces of
brave young soldiers
who have told me with their pride in
their eyes
how much they love serving this country
to every service member and to our
incredible military families
you are heroes and he will always be in
my thoughts
and prayers i think of all of the
members of law enforcement
who greet us everywhere we go
at every hour of every day they stand
guard to keep
our communities safe and we are forever
in their depth i have been moved by
children
i have visited in hospitals and foster
care centers
even as they fight difficult illnesses
or face
challenges they bring such a joy to
everyone they meet
i remember the mothers who have battled
the disease of opioid addiction
and have overcome incredible hardships
for love of their children
i have been inspired by the devoted
caregivers
for babies born with neonatal absence
syndrome
and communities that give these children
the support
and care they need to grow
when i think about these meaningful
experiences i'm humbled to have had the
opportunity
to represent a nation with such kind
and generous people as the world
continues to confront the covet 19
pandemic
i thank all of the nurses doctors
healthcare professionals manufacturing
workers
drug drivers and so many others who are
working to save lives
we grieve for the families who have lost
a loved one
due to the pandemic every life is
precious
and i ask all americans to use caution
and common sense
to protect the vulnerable as millions of
vaccines
are now being delivered in the midst of
hardship
we have seen the best of america shine
through
students have made cards and delivered
groceries
to our senior citizens teachers
have worked twice as hard to keep our
children learning
families have come together to provide
meals supplies
comfort and friendship to those in need
be passionate in everything you do but
always remember
that violence is never the answer
and will never be justified
when i came to the white house i
reflected on the responsibility i have
always felt
as a mother to encourage give strength
and teach values of kindness
it is our duty as adults and parents
to ensure that children have the best
opportunities
to lead fulfilling and healthy lives
the passion for helping children succeed
has driven my policy initiatives
as first lady i launched the best to
ensure
that we as americans are doing all we
can
to take care of the next generation
be best has concentrated on three
pillars
well-being online safety and opioid
abuse
in a few short years i have raised
awareness
of how to keep children safe online
we have made incredible progress on our
nation's
drug epidemic and how it impacts the
lives of newborns
and families and we have given a voice
to our most vulnerable children in their
foster care system
internationally best has evolved into a
platform
that encourages world leaders to discuss
issues impacting the lives of children
and allows them to share solutions
it has been an honor to represent
american people abroad
i treasure each of my experiences and
the inspiring people i have met
along the way as i say farewell
to my role as first lady it is my
sincere hope
that every american will do their part
to teach
our children what it means to be best
i encourage parents to educate your
children
about the courageous and selfless heroes
who worked and sacrificed to make this
country
the land of the free and to lead
by example and care for others in your
community
the promise of this nation belongs to
all of us
do not lose sight of your integrity and
values
use every opportunity to show
consideration
for another person and build good habits
into our daily lives in all
circumstances
i ask every american to be an ambassador
of be best to focus on what
unites us to raise above what divides us
to always choose love over hatred peace
over violence and others before yourself
together as one national family
we can continue to be the light of hope
for future generations
and carry on america's legacy of rising
our nation to greater heights through
our spirit of courage
goodness and faith
no words can express the death of my
gratitude
for the privilege of having served as
your first lady
to all the people of this country you
will be in my heart forever
thank you god bless you and god bless
the united states of america
yeah that's not a speech of four more
years
and and i just couldn't help but to
think that
as you brought up uh donald trump and
his inauguration 2017 speech
uh january 20th i'm remembered by the
speech that trump
gave in in 2019 september 24
2019 just before the covet pandemic
he spoke in front of the u.n you google
it on the youtube to come up
trump's un speech 2019
it was an epic speech
to all the dictators around the world
of how you should be treating your
people
and you should serve your people of your
country
and how america is doing just that
making america great
it was a phenomenal uh um
citizenry first speech
and then we had cobid and we had the
crazy nonsense
that's kind of too eerie looking back
how the timelines just kind of played
out how they said
oh hell no no no no
none of this let me ask you a question
were there riots
during uh trump's inauguration the
nights before
weren't they doing some things in dc
that they shouldn't have been doing
after yeah
march didn't they yeah the pink
march was after but the violence
was after the actually was the night of
the inauguration
it was the night of the inauguration of
crazy nonsense crazy marches crazy
crazies
out there that's what madonna said she
was gonna she was thinking about blowing
up the white house right
yeah that's the pink hats
wait okay was that before
i know trump was in office when she said
i just didn't know right around
okay it was after it was after it was
after he got in
is when is when she did that um
the media the median themselves
like and we will continue
to let you know this the media is going
after the trump influencers
the major people that helped him
um and the ones that he really even
didn't serve him well
they're going after them too anything
that had anything to do with president
trump
they're going after him uh and they're
going to deep
the platform uh the program
or tragedy program they they aren't
going as hard as they are going with
trump but they're going hard at many
people
um washington post columnist
said uh that they want a black loo black
list fox news as
we do with foreign terrorist groups they
somebody has handed out a piece of paper
to a lot of these news people
and all you're hearing is domestic
terrorists like we say early in the
program domestic terrorist terrorist
terrorist domestic terrorist
the law democracy for the law the
lawmakers are coming out now with that
the democrats are coming out and using
that word
if and i know many of you watch the show
or you might watch them on the podcast
or whatnot but you really don't
watch what happens in congress
and i suggest that you watch c-span for
the next two or three years
uh and turn off everything else but
watch c-span just keep
watch watch how government go i'm not
saying you don't understand government
i'm
just watch where it is right now
when when the democrats have a key word
that somebody
that these think tanks or group tanks
have given them it's in everybody's
speech
i don't i mean it's it's there it's like
oh
oh yeah i'm domestic terrorist next
person yeah we have to do something
about these domestic terrorists next
person
we have domestic terrorists they drive
at home just like the media does it too
and uh just like we're in this together
it was in everybody's speech
we're in this together oh i couldn't
stand that from the
new york times yeah from the new york
times to the l.a times
from the east coast to the west coast
and i think there's two reasons why
they're doing this obviously they hate
trump supporters they hate trump
but they also don't like competition
they don't like it that at your
fingertips they can
you can just put breaking news like
wayne dupree can put breaking news and
then
follow that up with a sentence right he
can do that quicker than what fox news
can
or cnn can off of a commercial break if
there's breaking news during commercial
break
they come back on and do the breaking
news i've seen many times that wayne has
got the story out
before cnn has do you really think they
like that
so it's kind of a double-edged sword
it's kind of like two reasons they don't
like you
but you're also their competition they
are at war with anybody that is giving
out news
they want to be the news so if they can
just become one big mainstream media
and not worry about you guys that are
giving the news quicker to people at
their fingertips
that's one less thing they have to
compete against i look i saw something
i i saw a commercial for c-span
no for cnn and they had the audacity to
say
uh we've gone through a tough time
but we and i'm paraphrasing but we
want to bring you back to where you can
trust the news and
you're the ones that freaked everything
out
you messed everything up you you went
out there
and went hard at somebody who said that
he wanted to make america great again
and you went hard at him because he
didn't want to go through you he didn't
want to
barack obama was the same thing barack
obama didn't want to go through the
media but the media didn't attack him
barack obama didn't
he treated the media toward the end i'm
talking about toward in
barack obama treated the media really
bad but they didn't attack him
but then when trump came in there it's
like oh
okay well we get we don't know what he's
going to do so they start making up
stuff
they start making up stuff because he
was going on his twitter so
so then they hired many people to watch
his twitter accounts
day in day out and then they developed
their narratives from that
and remember wayne whenever you said
yesterday about how we were changing
over to d
live instead of youtube we're doing g
live a lot of people don't like change
but change is inevitable that's how
things just move on
and i think what we're seeing here
remember when they said video killed the
radio star
because it did right and then what
happened to radio siriusxm came in
things like that right well then what
happened to newspapers yahoo came
in you're able to get your news just on
twitter well what happened to the media
on tv
it's dead it's dying okay so
fox news cnn emma nbc it's gonna all be
dead because we're all using our phones
now for the media
the best thing they can do is just do it
with their twitter accounts at this
point
because they're dying and the fox news
just changed their lineup cnn had some
lowest ratings they've ever had and i
get it that a lot of people blame it on
trump supporters on why cnn has low
ratings and
fox news is doing better but when you
look at it in a big spectrum
it's all dying because that's just where
we're going as
a as a country as a world and they
aren't taking that well they don't like
change and they are clawing their ways
they're biting their way to try to fight
this because they know they're dying
and honestly it's it's it's dying you
know what to
along with the media dying
i knew fox kept saying that they were
number one yada yada
but i knew they were in trouble when
they created that fox nation thing
right they tried to make a transition
didn't they they tried to
transition to online streaming but
but you wonder why because y'all number
one y'all getting on these big contracts
and for commercials and advertisements
and what nation wasn't a paid service
too
yeah right yeah it's kind of like
netflix
look at netflix there's a bunch of
little streaming services but the one
that you know is what netflix
look at amazon there's a bunch of little
shopping net shopping online places but
which one do you look at the most
amazon right well that's what's going to
happen with the media there's gonna be
one
major one that you go to well you don't
really trust and there's gonna be all
these million other news outlets
like what you're seeing now with us uh
and then you know you have other ones as
well but that's what you're gonna see in
the future and that's why the media is
panicking because they know they're
gonna just turn into one gigantic amazon
one gigantic netflix it's gonna be one
media company but then you're gonna have
a thousand others that you can go to
it that's they're dying
whether they're legal legal entities of
each other or not
we know they parroted each other across
the nation
yeah everything's gonna be gone and
it'll be one just like there's a netflix
just like there's an amazon there's
gonna be one main one
and then you have a million other ones
and quite frankly i'm okay with that
because i don't need to listen to the
main one not a lot of people will
it's kind of like do you want to shop at
amazon do you want to watch netflix or
would you rather watch
other things right would you rather buy
from other places that's how it's going
to be
i'm molly brown yeah that's good for me
and i kept telling people
don't put your money in fox nation
because oh it is awful
i didn't know anything about it i never
even tried it it's like the same people
that you watch for free now they're
saying pay for it
on fox nation it's like if it's news
then you have to give it to me
why should i log off and log on to the
thing to see
real news well until 1am and wait for
greg gutfeld and red eye
and that's great jeff janine's doing a
series on there and she's exploring
castles
i don't understand this i saw a
commercial judge
on saturday nights and she gives great
insight and then well we got to do
something else let's put her on
have her explore some castles it yeah i
don't know
and where it is
uh some of the people in congress
democrats want to
uh diminish newsmax and oan
well they're going to be diminished
anyways just like see they're all going
to be diminished
they're all going to go away and then
you'll get one main
outlet and then a bunch of millions you
watch oh yes cnn is claiming that
their numbers are big oh yeah well
they're getting sold by att so it
doesn't matter what their numbers are
18t doesn't want them
because att sees what's going to happen
they're all going away
um easy to predict newspaper it's
happened with radio it's happened with
newspapers
who is patrol who who is the troll in
the periscope y'all
who is the troll give me a name
give me a name because i think is it
blue note 44
do we want blue note gone
no not me somebody in the chat
talk here that's one yes cherie says yes
okay
okay all right blue note you know it's
it's
it's been awesome it's uh it's been
awesome knowing it's not out on a side
note not a balloon
i mean yeah
i'm so glad we have this time to spend
together
you're on the island
okay you got it okay great
we're getting ready to roll out of here
we'll be
yo what's up
um ladies and gentlemen here's the deal
tomorrow is the presidential
inauguration
tomorrow's presidential inauguration
many of you
many of you said that y'all were not
going to watch the inauguration
okay we understand that
we are news so i plan on covering it
[Music]
but i also want y'all to call in yeah
call in
let's point out all the terribleness of
it yeah exactly yeah call in and let's
just talk about what a disaster will be
let's make it our
our news okay let's make it hours now
i think uh i think we'll start off at um
11 o'clock
but let's make it our broadcast let's
make it
about us and um suggestions and
solutions about
going forward and what we need to do to
make things better
uh um going forward but um
you know and you know if y'all won't
make fun of him
y'all can make fun of him that's that's
your prerogative
but um it is news it is news
and we are news we are not um
we're not paid by huge companies or
anything
and we survive on what you give us
so i know you don't want us to skip a
day
i know you want to hear what we have to
say and we want to get right
i like that you like that yeah i'm
rapping
so you know we're just gonna hang out
tomorrow we're just gonna hang out
tomorrow and we're gonna hug each other
and we're going to hold hands together
and
that's what we're going to do what do
you think i was lady gaga singing or
she's spirit cooking i wasn't sure
exactly
why we're gonna mute her you know good
that's what i like to hear
yeah so jump over to patreon.com
backslash wd show
become a contributor i mean five bucks a
month that's literally only one of us
getting a cup of coffee
a month seriously i mean if you're going
to starbucks
so i mean you think about it 15 bucks a
month that's a
cup called for each one of us that
really helps to get the show out
really helps take care of the app which
is phenomenal helps take care of all
these different platforms to be able to
broadcast this
although you what you're seeing here is
on your little device
this is broadcast out throughout the
entire world
many different devices internet is the
app
you absolutely have to have in the time
and day and age we are in
where you don't know whose phone gets
shut down and what's going to happen
get the app you always to brian's point
the app
uh we were streaming on youtube it got
shut down so now we change it to d live
and you didn't have to do anything all
you had to do is just log back onto the
app that you already downloaded
and click press here and you're able to
watch us live now don't forget tomorrow
we're gonna take calls we want to hear
what you have to say and through this
app all you have to do is click on call
studio it's the third option down and
you can get uh
right populated in with wayne and us so
download the wayne dupree podcast all
you gotta do is type in wayne dupree
in your store that's all it's easy
that's right and let us not forget we
this show is being sponsored by
mypillow.com my pillow now
my mike lindell is under some serious
pressure
yes he's known there's some serious
pressure so if you
support mike lindell and you also
support the show but if you support
mike lindell we're asking you to go to
mypillar.com click on the radio specials
that's that blue button over top of the
the february 14th graphic
go to the website click on that and then
look at the specials
and then use the code name wayne okay
use your old name wayne but you'll be
helping him
because from what i hear uh bed bath and
beyond are gonna stop
sharing it uh stop selling the stuff
there's another company that is also not
sharing his
uh not selling his stuff because
dominion has come out
and they are well they were talking
about taking him to court
for what he has said about dominion so
he came back and said once you prove
that i'm wrong right
that was good that was a good comeback
yeah we were preaching that yesterday
yep
absolutely just remember your ground
remember god fights for those that are
on his side and you know
mike lindell is a very strong believer
in the lord
and i believe that he's got his back hey
remember the geese of sheets are buy one
get one free they also have them in
flannel as well
and it's still the giza cotton i just
want to share with you our friend kathy
kathy
short on the chat she actually texted me
yesterday and said she ordered the
towels and it's so cute
they say you are calling for wayne so
whenever you call the 800-889-0532
they'll actually come on and say hey you
calling for wayne there we go
yeah that's pretty cool so
um i know i know each of us have
our um
i can tell you this that mattress topper
i wake up in the middle of night every
night i have not woke up in the middle
of night since
i put the mattress stopper on yeah yeah
i'm only laughing because um biden has
this transgender woman
uh assistant health secretary i know we
cracked on her out of pennsylvania we
made fun of her
but i and you know
it's easy to make jokes when people look
kind of weird yeah
i did not know it was truly a training i
did
that would make sense i did i did that
would make sense
oh boy this is identity politics
at its finest yeah yeah yeah
i mean she has put he she
has put nothing to the table with
pennsylvania in fact they screwed it up
they have screwed up so much for this
state
i'm here trust me i can tell you that so
what joe biden did there
was just identity politics
right and here i i thought it was
i thought it was kind of strange that
president trump lifted the travel
restrictions
i really thought it was strange i'm like
wait a minute
you listening to travel restrictions
really and and what did bond do wait
wait wait wait wait hold on put him back
on put him
but you were complaining about them in
the first place y'all were saying that
he was uh
islamophobic or all these publics and
stuff and everything
so but now you want him to put the
restrictions back on
yeah they're up on january 26th
and trump was keeping the travel
restrictions on
iran and a part of brazil but letting
them
up for the uk and other places and by
administration was like nope in fact
we're talking even stricter restrictions
we want people to start restricting
their travel all together i mean it's
gonna
man you know what i'll be honest with
you
i don't think that's bad idea biden i
said go ahead shut the border down
shut the border down the north the south
the east and the west
shut it down just shut it down for a
while well it's interesting what he ran
on and what he's doing
right immigration nope nope
opening the borders it's completely
opposite he's literally
we all voted joe we're laughing at you
yeah
it's gonna be a civil war in the
democratic party already because
he's already closed the borders to the
to the hondurans
he's closing the borders to the other
people
and that's all y'all love is those open
borders man
that's all you love someone can do that
all right uh any last words
yeah um the media is so obsessed with
everything but joe biden's terrible
decisions and how he
can't even finish a sentence that
they're now talking about his peloton
did you hear this
they're worried that he's going to bring
his peloton into the white house and
it's going to be a security issue
because
people can hack into it and then watch
him exercising
and they'll know they'll know where he's
at and what he's doing i'm sorry but i
don't want to watch that
that frankly old thing on a peloton
all right i don't want to see that brian
ah just a shout out to mike lindell and
from
crack addict the ceo what a phenomenal
american story
truly an american story uh he found god
found god through christ
uh got himself clean and i i think he
had a fallout went back
and then for a second time got clean
again and stayed clean
he's done a phenomenal job and helping
those that need a second chance
helping those that need to get off the
streets that want to
that are sick and tired of being sick
and tired and truly want
a better life and to find that better
life through our savior jesus christ
uh we're partnering with the church here
locally that's been doing the same thing
and i'm shocked my perspective
has truly been changed uh by watching
uh men and women get clean and do that
through the church without
uh methadone without other drugs i mean
ironic
that it wants to give you drugs to get
off
drugs i digress but but the whole thing
is with with mike lindell
phenomenal support him um support
everything that he's doing
and uh you know he's right you know he's
right
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen we are
the wayne dupree show me uh we're here
monday tuesday and we
oh yeah whoa whoa there we go
i broke the code i want everybody to
really call in tomorrow i want to hear
some good calls tomorrow yeah so please
come and visit don't be afraid i mean
we're all family here you know just call
in let us know
i mean if you want to make fun make fun
yeah just do that
we're giving you the space you don't
have to give your name and we are and we
definitely aren't giving your phone
number out to anybody so
call in talk to us um
so uh we'll probably start around 11
o'clock tomorrow we're not going to go
through it
it's like mitch mcconnell's going to
church with um
oh biden he didn't go to church with
trump but he's going to church for biden
he's going to church tomorrow oh old
[ __ ] mitch is going to um
go to church oh [ __ ] look i
i haven't seen that many devils in
church since uh
since i was a kid wait this one burned
down
[Laughter]
mitch could sing that holy water on him
it might give him more
black blue marks
[Laughter]
all right we gotta go we see y'all
tomorrow uh god bless
and uh if you want to uh
support the show go to patreon.com
forward slash
wd show patreon.com forward slash wd
show
we're almost at a hundred and fifty and
i know
oh wow i know the number one friday show
don't they
yeah i know the numbers keep going down
and going up and down because some
people
they they they join but then a couple
might leave at the same time
so basically we're trying to get 500
that's our goal
500 we're at 149.
yeah our friday show will be a wild card
you don't know if we're going to do
relationships
we do anything you tell us a topic we'll
and then we'll do
it we'll do anything friday friday is so
freaking open
uh and i'm on the wild card i'll let you
know this too
going forward starting tomorrow well
after tomorrow we're going to change up
the format a little bit
okay we know we know
we know some of you want politics
politics policies all the time
but um we're going to change up the
format a little bit to add a little bit
more
lifestyle type of things on the show
you won't get bored i promise you not
with us three no
no no no no
this would be like seeing our text
message behind the scenes
whenever we're talking other things yeah
because then we can kind of let our
guard down and
yeah say what we want yeah i mean we're
gonna we're gonna
touch some things that uh uh and we're
gonna have fun with it too
yeah we're gonna have fun we're gonna
argue we'll argue something too
but uh it's it's all about changing
up some stuff because we're gonna be
targeted
and many of you support us and a whole
lot of you don't
and we can't continue if you don't
support us that's just
that's just how it is holly said i'm
ready for a change tired of talking
about those idiots in washington yeah
we're gonna change it up a little bit
yeah yeah we're gonna change it up a
little bit so uh
with that said y'all y'all have been
very good to us thank you
all the beautiful people watching on d
live uh
again if you are if you're on pa if
you're on periscope
we're telling you this right now you
only have three more weeks
you only have a few more weeks right
follow us
on d live under wayne the pre-show or
rumble because romo is going to have
live stream
soon too all right all right
god bless